today's episode is not for everybody
it's gonna sting a little bit for some
of you if you do watch it so if you're
not in the mood to be challenged
I suggest you skip in today's video I'm
Patrick made evident today I wanted to
talk to you about one of the most
difficult things for all of us to do
that is required to do if you choose to
want to live a happier more fulfilling
life with more experiences greater
experiences this is a must because
without this it's very very difficult so
a few days ago we were having a
conversation with one of our friends and
he was sitting there and another girl
was sitting there and you know the girls
start saying that I don't need any man I
don't need any man to do anything for me
I don't need any man to help me out I
don't need any man support me I can
handle my own finances I make my own
money I need no one's help and in the
conversation led to but I'm looking for
a husband and it's so hard to find a
husband why am I having such a hard time
finding a husband you were just kind of
listening to her right and I sat down
and thought about I said wait a minute
men want to marry woman because they
also want to felt need it
men want to feel that someone needs them
you need me for security you need me
because I make you feel safe because I
make you fall because I fulfill you
because you need me and I want to feel
needed I don't want to not feel needed I
want you to need me
that's oh no why why do I exist if you
don't need me what's the purpose of me
being if you don't need me why would you
need me if you don't what's the purpose
of the whole relationship here but the
same goes for guys you're not some guy
said you know what I don't need it any
girl to make me happy or satisfied me or
this this this this denim I don't need
this I can please I can do this I can do
that mom I don't need anyone now you go
into their house you know you go into
their apartment and you walk into their
room you know what happens seriously
there's like dead cats and dogs all over
the place your clothes everywhere mess
everywhere they don't have the best
people skills their heart is not the
best way on dealing with people and they
find and they say I don't need it but I
want to get married I want to find it
how come they're having a hard time
finding a girl because a woman almost
also wants to feel needed do you realize
how much I need
my wife I need my family
I need help I need help
you see one person on the camera today
you're only looking at me you know what
you don't see you don't see Mario here
you don't see all the people here
working in the background
you don't see any the stuff we run a
company with thousands of people all
across the country you don't see the
support you don't see the mark you don't
see any that stuff but I see it because
I need everybody's help
I need everybody so and I'm comfortable
with that but it took years to realize
why we have a hard time saying I need
your help I need you do you know why we
have a hard time saying I need you here
is why so think about where that feeling
of saying I don't need anybody so what
do you think that feeling comes from it
comes from ego pride and someone you
relied on when you were younger let you
down
disappointed you so you grew up saying I
don't need anybody so I can do it all by
myself
you know what the reality is take
everybody in the world that there's 7
billion people living in the world let
you say we cut everybody but there's one
person left it's you how's life you
don't need anybody so how's life looking
what are you gonna be like that guy
hanging out with Wilson the volleyball
talking to mile day long painting is
that what's gonna happen with what was
that movie's name by the way with Tom
Hanks Cass plates that was that what the
case is gonna be listen the sooner you
realize you need people sell theirs
sooner you're gonna be able to get other
people to come and say I need you as
well I need you I need you I need you
now I'm not talking about needy because
there's two different ends of the
spectrum on need one is the side that
one person feels like they need know
oneself and another person's that they
need everybody so there's got to be a
balance where you're about to in the
middle you know you you need other
people separate you also you've got to
be able to stand up and do your own
thing and provide me for other people
too at the same time so so I told you
this message may sting a little bit so
maybe you needed to not watch this video
right and on the other hand maybe you
needed to watch this video to help you
with some of your relationship in your
life that are doing so much for you you
just got to realize it's okay that I
need people the bigger the things I want
to do in life them use them more people
I'm going to
need and I'm comfortable with that it's
my message of the week to you and I need
you to subscribe to this channel and
comment on the bottle thank you for
watching